DSM is providing the application developer with a programming model
on a cluster that is akin to P threads on an SMP. It looks and feels like a
shared memory threads package. That's good. But
what about performance? Will the performance of
a multi-threaded app. Scale up as we
increase the number of processors in the cluster.
Now, from an application programmer's point of view, your
expectation is that, as you add more processors, you're
going to get more performance. That's your expectation. And what
we are doing is, we're exploiting the parallelism that is
available both in the application because it's structured in
that way. And in the hardware, in order to get
increase performances as you increase the number of processors.
But the problem is as you increase the number of
processors because things are happening in software, there
is increased overhead as well. And this overhead
increases as the number of processors, so the
actual performance is going to be actually much
less than your expectation. Mitigated by the increasing
overhead with the number of processors. And this
buildup of overhead with a number of processes,
happens in a true memory multi-processors. And this
is even more true in the case of liason. Which
is implementing the shared memory extraction in software on a cluster.